après quoi
après la diffusion américaine craignant
on se dépêche je me mets pas la pression
je sais c'est pas parce que chez ocs ils
vont plus vite que les autres que nous
on va arrêter de respecter les
limitations de vitesse avec us + 24 /
ocs vos séries préférées sont
disponibles dès le lendemain de la
diffusion américaine jamais de mon
vivant une série us ne sera diffusé que
les bouffeurs de grenouilles de normatif
américaine avait tué ce +24 sur ocs vos
séries préférées sont disponibles dès le
lendemain de la diffusion américaine
michel françoise on se bouge la halle et
françoise voilà michel on va être encore
24 heures a lyon des pêches avec us + 24
/ ocs vos séries préférées sont
disponibles dès le lendemain de la
diffusion américaine faudrait mon petit
man dans 24 heures on a rendez vous en
france
ah ouais c'est comme ça maintenant à vos
ordres on n'a plus un moment de répit
c'est mais pense à tous tes fans
français qui tâtonnent sur cf j'arrive
jason va peut-être mettre un petit slip
avant de partir avec us + 24 / ocs vos
séries préférées sont disponibles dès le
lendemain de la diffusion américaine
j'en peux plus 24 heures c'est tout ce
qui blesse j'espère que ça en vaut la
peine
moshi au bout du rouleau comme ça avec
us + 24 / ocs vos séries préférées sont
disponibles dès le lendemain de la
diffusion américaine